we're continuing our conversation with
christian peachelini who's founder of
the free radicals project
host of breaking hate on msnbc
also author of the book white american
youth so in part one of the interview
christian we talked about how you got
into the neo-nazi skinhead movement and
some of the sort of characteristics of
folks that are particularly drawn to it
and targets for recruiters
before we get into how you got out of
the movement i'd be interested in
hearing a little bit about
how you see what's going on today we had
the one year anniversary recently of the
charlottesville virginia rally that led
to the death of one woman and many
injuries a rally about which
the president of the united states said
there were very fine people on both
sides including the side that included
neo-nazis and white supremacists
do you see the current resurgence
as directly connected to who's in the
white house or is it more complicated
than that
i think it's slightly more complicated
than that but i will say that
uh you know the election did
uh kick over a bucket of gasoline that
was already
that kind of ignited all the small fires
that already existed
around america um you know i i certainly
think that
uh you know we can refer to the
statements made by the white
nationalists themselves
uh from david duke to richard spencer to
matthew heimbach to
you know many of the prominent leaders
within the white nationalist movement
who came out and said
you know we've elected our man uh you
know we're excited about the policies
that
he's implementing uh you know from
building a wall to a muslim ban
to uh you know tearing uh families
uh away from each other and deporting
them
these are all these are all white
nationalist talking points and they were
thrilled
uh when trump was elected president um
you know hate crimes have been up i mean
the statistics are all there the facts
uh
you know can't be ignored and certainly
some of the policies and the words that
he's used himself can't be ignored so
uh you know i certainly think it has
fueled uh
i don't know if we'd call it a
resurgence but it's it's certainly uh
it's bigger but it's it's more that it's
come out of the shadows uh than it was
trump did not create racism my sense has
been that there's not
so so much more or new
white supremacists and neo-nazis but
there's more
comfort in just kind of saying that
those are your views
and in demonstrating publicly do you
agree or do you think that there's
actually
individuals who are entering the
movement as a result of what's going on
oh i think there are absolutely more
people entering the movement as a result
oh you do that's much worse than i was
hoping
well you know the tactics have changed
in the platforms uh
with which they they reach people have
have changed so i think the internet is
really uh it's kind of like my digital
alley right
uh you know for so many young kids you
know kids who feel marginalized rather
than going to smoke pot in an alley
like i did are now going to hang out in
chat rooms and in forums and and
you know places like 4chan and reddit
and in those places they're starting to
see these very kind of benign
uh you know white nationalist recruiting
lures
like i saw you know things about
identity politics and and uh you know
black on white crime statistics that are
falsified and
and even skepticism towards the
holocaust so it's not
you know th the new wave of this kind of
pseudo-intellectual
thinking that's influencing so many
young people both on the internet and in
real life
you know they're they're not calling
themselves holocaust deniers they're not
calling themselves white nationalists
they're skeptics
they're scientists uh they're
philosophers who are just searching for
the truth and that's the way they hide
uh you know the racism and the ideas
that they're trying to push and so many
people
david are falling victim to this and
they're not white not all of them
yeah well that's what i wanted to kind
of ask about because you mentioned the
idea of people who don't even
realize that even if they don't consider
themselves part of any of these
movements
by their mere sort of acceptance of some
of the ideas they're becoming and this
isn't an insulting term it's
a term that has a specific meaning a
useful idiot right someone who is
without being aware of it serving a
particular purpose that they're not even
necessarily connected to what are some
examples of that
well yeah no i mean i think useful idiot
is a really great way to put it it's an
intelligence term that means somebody's
been compromised without really their
knowledge
and they're being put to use without
knowing what they're doing
uh you know and i think a lot of uh you
know famous uh writers people like
jordan peterson or podcasters like sam
harris and certainly uh
you know these kind of pseudo uh
philosopher types like stefan molino
from canada uh uh you know are very good
at
hiding uh the fact and again whether
it's intentional or not i don't know
they could be useful
idiots although i would say that molino
is very uh well aware of what he's doing
and the other two may not be
they're pushing these ideas that are
gateway drugs essentially to white
nationalism when they start talking
about
skepticism of the holocaust uh or the
fact
uh you know based on the bell curve
charles murray's bell curve that
uh you know whites and asians have a
higher iq
because of genetics than than africans
and and
other people of color no christian i
know because i haven't heard one of the
people you mentioned peterson harris and
molyneux
which which ones are doing the holocaust
skepticism because that i genuinely
haven't heard from them
so stefan molyneux has several videos um
where he's talked about it where he's
you know he's freight and he's from
canada too so he has to be very specific
about what he can and can't say about
the holocaust because
uh denying it there is part of their
hate speech laws and he can be arrested
uh but you know he's he's towed the line
he's come to it and posed the question
uh you know did it you know i'm not
quoting
uh but did it happen you know he kind of
elicits people to think on it
kind of with the notion that perhaps it
didn't um
you know i can't tell you how many
parents uh i get emails from that say
you know i've lost my son or my daughter
to stefan molinel
uh you know there was a point where he
was encouraging his
his millions of followers uh to defu
their parents and dfu stands for to uh
to remove yourself from your family of
origin
yeah because he thought that that you
know parents were inherently
uh you know awful uh for the development
of children
i suspect he probably had a really bad
uh situation you know in his childhood
that
made him believe that but certainly i
would i would argue that
you know parents are not awful for
children unless the parents are awful
people
um but you know and he's always kind of
shape-shifting into this very
nationalist
uh you know very kind of white
nationalist uh viewpoint i mean even so
far as david duke praising him and
retweeting him and
and and things like that so he'll deny
it uh
until he's blue in the face but uh you
know i can tell you that for somebody
like me those aren't dog whistles those
are bull horns i hear those things loud
and clear
because i used to do the same thing i
used to mask my true intentions
and and make the words a little bit more
palatable for people to swallow
so that i could recruit them so that i
could put my ideas in their head
and essentially bait them so i could
reel them in later
and you know unfortunately i think so
many of their listeners of of molino and
harris's and
and even peterson's readers uh are
falling victim to
these ideas that are just really garbage
science and
and very racist in nature so you've
talked a lot about
how the pulling into the movement
happens
either through the sort of useful idiot
stuff
or direct recruiting as you were
directly recruited when you were 14
can you talk now a little bit about how
you get out and maybe start with you i
mean what
what started to turn for you that you
eventually got out of the neo-nazi
skinhead movement
well you know having been born with
racism not a part of my dna certainly
helped i mean
i for every day of those eight years
that i was involved i questioned
my involvement unfortunately that what i
was getting from it in terms of you know
this perception of power
and his perception of strength i started
to become really
intoxicated with with it uh and nothing
that presented itself even though it was
better was
was powerful enough to to draw me away
until
i started to actually meet the people
that i thought i hated i i'd opened a
record store in 1995
to sell white power music because that
was the world that i lived in i was in a
band and was really all i knew since i
was 14.
and uh but i also sold hip hop and punk
rock and heavy metal to make ends meet
and you know i started to meet
african-american people and jewish
people and gay people
and muslims and and all of a sudden uh
not all of a sudden but
you know over time at the store i had to
deal with these customers and i began to
realize that you know i had much more in
common with them than i did with
the people i'd surrounded myself with to
boost my own ego
and it was really the compassion that
these people showed me even though they
knew exactly who i was and what i was
about
and what i was selling in my store they
came in and chose to treat me with
compassion
uh and it was the compassion that i
received from them one
you know the people at least deserved it
from when i least deserved it i think
that was my most powerful
uh catalyst for change i just couldn't
reconcile my prejudice the demonization
that i had for these people now that i'd
met them and had
a meaningful engagement with them was
destroyed and it became
you know turned into humanization and i
just couldn't deny
um the truth anymore so
did you talk about that with the other
neo-nazi
skinhead people that you were around did
you say you know i'm starting to kind of
question
or was that was that an internal
dialogue exclusively
oh it was internal uh because you know
there was always a fear of
of seeming weak or being vulnerable
uh within the movement you know it
wasn't something that
wasn't something that most people did
you know you were talking about a bunch
of
you know type a alpha males or people
you know or males who were trying to be
that and uh you know
talking about your feelings and your
emotions wasn't always a good thing
unless it was about anger and violence
uh so i struggled with it internally
actually you know i struggled there for
the last two years i was in the movement
and i still couldn't leave
even though i was you know it was
devastating me uh
devastating me so much that i lost my
wife and my children because of it
because i didn't leave the movement fast
enough for them they were never
involved and you know the lure of this
kind of identity community and purpose
that i had found in the movement was
was too strong and i didn't have the
courage to to walk away until you know i
hit rock bottom and then
i really had no choice and when you do
that is it
a clean break is there i mean is it easy
to leave
i don't this isn't this is a poor
analogy but we've interviewed a lot of
former scientologists who say
you don't just leave right like i mean
there's physical things keeping you
there there are financial things keeping
you there
etc can you just say i'm out and that's
it
yeah i wish it were that easy but it's
not uh you know everything that i had
was invested in that movement uh you
know much like the story of the
scientologist and really you know
becoming a neo-nazi or becoming a part
of a white supremacist movement is
really not that different than a cult
or the islamic state or gang uh
or a sports team or a religious group i
mean
it was the same type of draw it was that
you know sense of belonging in the sense
of
this is who i am and this is what i'm
supposed to do with my life
um so it was very difficult uh to walk
away from that because it was really
everything that i had ever known and i
had nothing to go back to
and the threat of you know leaving
certainly the physical violence was
always there but also the threat of
not being accepted by uh you know
everybody else once you left was
was always a big threat you know like
drug users maybe it's sometimes just
easier to go back uh and for many people
that's what happens unfortunately if we
don't replace it with a new
identity community and purpose and
frankly my struggle
getting out which i you know i had to uh
i
had to question myself for many years i
had to do a lot of soul searching i had
to make amends
and seek forgiveness uh when i
eventually found the courage to tell
my story uh was a long process and it's
precisely the reason why i
i founded uh the original organization
uh
life after hate and also now free
radicals project was to actually help
people
go through that that transition and then
it kind of morphed into
proactively uh you know inserting
ourselves to try and get people to
disengage
last thing i want to touch on in the
time we have left um there's sort of
i guess to use an analogy there's retail
and wholesale strategies for getting
people
out of the movement so daryl davis for
example who we've interviewed several
times who's awesome
he has more of like a retail approach
where he will go and
individually hang out with kkk members
and other
neo-nazis etc the southern poverty law
center
has what they consider to be more of
like a wholesale approach where they are
trying to dismantle the groups from the
top
down given all options do you have
strong feelings about
what the most effective way is to
disrupt
or take apart these groups
well i think uh both strategies are
important i think we do need to
you know have a wholesale or a
preventative strategy
but we also have to to you know treat
the illness
uh patient by patient it's almost like
polio right
you know we have to treat sick people
which is what daryl and i do
to a large degree but we also have to
inoculate the population from getting
sick which is in large part what
groups like the splc or the
anti-defamation league or many of these
other
uh groups that are countering hate do
and i kind of do a little bit of both so
my goal is really to
educate people um you know through
different mechanisms like my talks the
tv show breaking hate
uh to be able to show people what they
can do uh because i know that you know
people like me and daryl
are are far in few between um
but that we also can uh that we can
destroy
this type of interpersonal racism now
i'm not talking about systemic or
institutional because that's a whole
other thing that we need to tackle as
well if we want to see racism
go away but as far as interpersonal
racism
you know this is something everybody can
do so long as we can
start to understand that ideology is not
what is radicalizing people
the pre-radicalization happens from the
day we're born
and it continues through every situation
that we have
until that extremist group presents
itself at which point we're radicalized
uh so my pre-radicalization was fraught
with abandonment and and with low
self-esteem
and confidence issues for some people
it's sexual abuse or
uh you know mental illness things like
that that
is though all those points of
marginalization trauma
those pain points that kind of just
nudges from our path that is the
radicalization process
the ideology when it presents itself is
just the permission slip
and the license to be angry uh and for
and for some people
uh you know they're lucky enough to
never come across that
that uh recruitment point uh and they
may go into drugs or they may get into
prostitution or they
may commit suicide it's all these other
kind of destructive behaviors
but people in hate movements hate people
not because of the color of their skin
but because they hate themselves
they're projecting their own pain onto
other people their own
feelings of uh of inadequacy of of
of you know whatever it is that's
troubled them
these groups have given them the
permission to project that pain onto
other people
and for many of these folks to feel good
about themselves making somebody feel
worse than they do is sometimes the only
way they can do that
um so you know i would caution but also
i think it's hopeful
that we know that uh because if we know
that it's these things that happen to us
throughout our lives that cause us to go
into these extremist groups that
that essentially allow us to hurt other
people yeah we can
fill those potholes and fix those people
with better social services with better
mental health
uh services in states there are some
states that don't even have that kind of
stuff i mean it's terrible
sometimes to think how our system is
really not serving uh its citizens but
you know if we can i think we can
largely um
i think we can largely solve this issue
of violent
hatred and and extremism if we can fill
those potholes
uh for kids at an early age christian
petrolini
founder of the free radicals project
host of breaking hate on msnbc and you
can also check out his book white
american youth
christian i really appreciate you taking
some time to talk to me today
david it's my pleasure thanks for having
me